c'est là d'ailleurs attrapé spyker s'est
pas foutu et non ouais ouais ouais pas
sortir on salue les non plus audrey sa
gauche
voilà malherbe est pas droite bref allez
musique ou ali est honnie paris le peu
peur voilà voici des lumières aller
sa revente ils sont fous je vais essayer
ça merde hathaway qui avait annoncé à
way you lie au nord-est où le groupe
était bien là tu appelles points à celle
là est accélérée là c'est joli c'est
joli et vous aussi vous dans la
brillance ça va être chaud ouais super
flic un peu ton casque sans fils sans je
peux pas un peu assez vous dirais que
c'est vous parce qu'il ya c'est que
l'espace younes a pas toujours mais
cette fois ça se sent ça du cycle 30
nage dans la vue henri 250e victoire de
là et on va les rejoindre
asif hervé partie
évidemment ils sont où ça prend la
parole devant ce parterre longtemps et
je vous parie de casse bien cliqué assez
tard il a trois qui sont cachés juste
devant moi ou ça va ce cas là il sort et
à deux autres n'ont pas tardé pensions a
encore deux autres à droite la droite
tape à la droite parce que ta main
droite
voilà encore un autre à droite à gauche
à droite bon ben voilà
ok après temps des seigneurs
là ils sont passés à l'ombre un geste au
premier au premier plan non alors
c'est qu'on a fait tous les autres tant
dans le sens
fait l'effort la fff
s'apprête lui à
tvo a même senti sion ok ok est ce que
tu veux
voilà et bien en fait le delta dans
lequel il bat donc tout le congrès sur
l'egypte ou pas ce faste
c'est clair les cadres à droite sans vie
messi est un parti toile voilà il a plus
ça va plus je conviens l'ombre mais
peut-être qu'on allait retrouver en
europe à l'action vers le pop star ouais
je suis comme je suis or pendant qu'ils
changent de colette tanguy est ce que tu
peux essayer mais